[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
[ __ ] asses what are we talking about
what are we talking about i haven't seen
a movie in so long it's like making me
sad
i want to watch billing's head so like
in the theater me too
casey's trying to get us to go to san
diego to watch tennis i heard that it's
just really loud
because that's the nearest the nearest
theater is in san diego san diego is the
only one that's open right now not even
oh no to play
tennis oh like lieutenant is only in
select theaters and the
nearest one to us is all the way down
there and do you know if it's like i
don't know they were open in san diego
is it like every other chair is that how
that works yeah so
oh michael went recently yeah and yeah
so he
was saying that there is like a six foot
distance apart so the theaters that they
got or that he went to
was like these like big old like couch
kind of seating so there's already a lot
of space in front and behind you kind of
like an eye pick
yeah it's kind of like that and then
also they don't sit anyone next to you
so there's a six
foot distance because we were about
we're about to buy tickets but then when
you look at the seating
it looks like there's like a regular
theater where it's like someone's
sitting in front of you someone's
sitting
behind you but they they block out the
seas next to you and i told casey i'm
like
i'm not gonna go if there's someone in
front of someone behind but then after
they went
they told us what happened now we're
like oh okay well that makes sense so
it's a six
foot round perimeter yeah it's a goddamn
dream is what it is
true but they say that you can take off
your mask while you're eating so then
if you're eating popcorn the whole time
then you don't have to wear the mask the
whole time
yeah that's how it seems like or you
just put a thing of popcorn on your lap
don't eat [ __ ] and just take you off the
mask yeah you caught a hole put your
dick inside oh no that's pretty good
okay i've heard that works
no but dude i like the worst thing about
movies in the olden days
is sitting next to a stranger but i
think after probably after covid
we'll never have to deal with that [ __ ]
again [ __ ] people yeah
oh yeah i have an article later today
that talks all about like oh
what are the cool things that are gonna
happen after this and that's
that's number one for me i think cause
sitting next to strangers in the movies
is always weird i don't like crowds
anyway it's the crowds for nikki but
when it's like a really anticipated
movie
and there's some of those moments the
energy of the room
adds to it though yeah for sure no i'm
cool people laugh when they're not
supposed to laugh
i like those a lot i love those laughs
what happened there
that that was me during every jennifer
lopez movie
well that was us during uh [ __ ] fast
and furious
everything during the wedding scene yeah
during all these the freeway scene yeah
every time they say brotherhood i laugh
out loud
and they say it a lot do you get tired
of laughing no i do i leave with the
[ __ ] that was
one of the first things that we watched
when we started dating was one of the
fast and the furious ones i can't
remember that's seven i think okay oh
geez i can't remember which one it was
but
um in the movie vin diesel gives uh
his name's just funny his real name he
gives it
like the girl across it was like a this
this cross jewelry okay
and it's like a sentimental moment so i
had to drop steve off at the airport to
go to portland
and i got him a jewelry cross and i gave
it to him and
i said whatever line it was it was
[ __ ] hilarious it's pretty special
until we first started dating i do still
have it actually it's in my laptop bag
yeah i was like hey
be careful out there or whatever it is
she said the vin line
in a crackly voice and i was very
confused at first and then i opened my
hand and i was like oh my god
she's sick dude she just did a fast and
the furious reference like this is my
stomach
when bean diesel got married in a tank
top i was crying laughing
and everyone was like taking it as a
serious moment
and that's when i realized i am not so
trash after all yeah right
i like that somebody's like hey man what
the [ __ ] dude this is a serious i know
right
and he's in a [ __ ] white beater just
straight up
i think it was that movie it was i was
like what the [ __ ] like
isn't this funny that's the one where
they've jumped out of one car like two
cars are
doing this thing and he jumps out of one
and catches michelle rodriguez
how many times has she died in those
movies by the way did she die in every
other one or what
every single fast movie oh my god dude
anybody who dies in that movie comes
back
you know the guy from tokyo drift is
coming except for one person one person
which one well didn't his brother play
the
that was good guys damn [ __ ] i felt that
one
it's like the one person everyone thinks
of but his character's still alive right
they could actually maybe bring him back
eventually that would be horrible that's
not watching around six or seven i don't
know
like what number are they on now 14 or
something yeah something like that but i
missed them all now they brought that
that princess leia back for the last one
princess leia the last star wars yeah
the cgi star wars star wars they just
stared at each other
[Laughter]
i don't know i don't like star wars no
more something happened yeah i just
started progressively not liking it got
popped disney that's what happened
i don't know yeah that's when it started
getting bad although people like that
mandalorian [ __ ] they like that [ __ ] i
like that show
i haven't seen it i haven't seen it you
should see it the mandalorian oh
baby yoda so [ __ ] cute that looks
cute we watched the really coolest um
two couple of documentaries and they're
about octopuses
octopus octopi's octopussies just say it
octopuses yeah delicious and i think
they're my favorite animal in the world
but they're ugly
they're so cute because they're so they
change colors they change texture yeah
but you can't
pet them yeah yes you can what you just
said
is so [ __ ] cute you could have been a
third grader because the [ __ ]
octopus is my favorite animal in the
whole world
and then everyone else in class is like
ew
she's like no they're really smart like
that makes it cuter you can't pet them
but you can they are really smart though
so so basic premise is this guy's a
filmmaker all his life
he's now in like his mid 50s maybe early
60s he's completely burnt out
he doesn't he's burnt out to the point
that he doesn't want to make or touch
anything with a [ __ ] camera
so now he goes to his house in like
africa or something
but he's being filmed by a camera no no
no uh well well
he goes to this to take a 20-year break
yeah so he goes to this house and he
just wants to get connected with nature
again because he remembers taking
playing octopus well wait he remembers
taking a trip to like a safari trip and
then the locals there were really good
at tracking
so they would look at like the dirt or
like how i don't know a plant would
break and they're like oh [ __ ]
it's going this way so there was
something human pooped here yeah like
they can see a lot of signs that we
since we're not accustomed to it we just
don't see it and he like kind of envied
that in a good way
so then he's like dude i want to get
close to nature and he'd really love to
see so he starts swimming
and as he's swimming like he notices
it's like an underground like
forest right and he's like it's like
this dope forest because i'm like
literally flying through this thing
so as he's looking at it and he's trying
to start tracking things he finds this
octopus
and then he gets really tight with her
and that's when the story progresses and
it's so beautiful
they're like friends and [ __ ] yeah so
like it took like you see him
because now like at this point he's he
has this new love for the ocean so now
he wants to document
he's drawing the ocean like he's mapping
it like a forest like oh this is where
this
coral is this is where this caliper so
he's mapped understanding the the layout
exactly
and he starts really studying like all
the animals and then when he
uh started interacting with this octopus
he found out that the octopus has the
intelligence of a cat and a dog
so they're actually very like the way a
dog interacts with you it's like a
dog of the ocean but did he get hungry
and i eat i was gonna say knowing that
doesn't it make you not want to eat him
no that we had this conversation in bed
and i was like i don't think i can ever
eat that and then i started going into
like me
being vegetarian or coming becoming
vegetarian then having to turn that part
off my brain and he's like dude i could
have a dog as a pet like i could
literally pet a dog while i'm eating a
dog we know you could
i'm like so this dogs i'm like this
dog's mine [ __ ] this guy
yeah when you asked him that question
i'm like let me give you some context
i'll eat a monkey before i eat a dog
good you have morals
i'll eat both [ __ ] i don't know do
you know octopus moms
they sacrifice yes all she kept doing
was cleaning
and just making sure that they're safe
and she didn't eat for like they starve
themselves to death to protect their
babies who does the mom octopuses it's
called um
my teacher the octopus yeah wait how do
a mom octopus
feed the baby octopus uh they got milk
they don't
got like 200 tickets they're born in sex
yeah she guarded the eggs
yes she's just constantly cleaning
because if she leaves the eggs then they
might get eaten by a predator
it's their fault they taste so good what
do they taste like
never eaten it's different like fresh
octopus it's different from like
what you get in sushi like fresh is like
the texture is
super soft it melts in your mouth it's
actually kind of sweet it wiggles in
your mouth a little bit
yeah the whip it's raw yeah you see
those videos of the girl trying to eat
the live octopus the big one that's just
crazy
that's as disgusting they say like
two-thirds of their brains are on their
like tentacles
oh really yeah two thousand suckers so
that's like imagine having two thousand
fingers like how much you can feel
that's like us but with our dicks
because we think with our dicks
yeah two-thirds of my cognition is on my
penis
guys would probably be much smarter if
we didn't think with our dicks they can
like detect volcanoes before any other
fishes
wow i know i just pictured you in third
grade
saying exactly that again with the
crayon dry especially with your hair
then they can even detect volcanoes wow
wow like octopuses like me
and i was like nah you're lame there's i
like my cat
my cat she gives me purse every day yay
cats cats yeah i love cats
my mom's here she brought it and
everyone can pet your mom's here too
yeah hi hi like okay be gentle
everyone she's kind of scared oh cute
excuse me can i
pet him oh i didn't get my tire to pet
it and she's like don't let joe pit it
i was so mad i couldn't bring my cat to
school because my mom's like i have work
all day
like kids always brought pets in
backpacks
well bart that's a different
neighborhood
yeah that didn't stop bark oh well
speaking of food
and this is non-animal food this is
yummy plants and fruit okay okay okay
shout out to our sponsor daily harvest i
really like daily harvest because they
have these ready to go breakfast things
that unlike other oatmeal even if you go
to like your local coffee shop
it's dried fruits that you throw in your
oatmeal these guys use
whole fruits so i really like that
because it's really easy to go they have
overnight oats
acai bowls like just really quick to eat
food from daily harvest and i really
really love them
daily harvest delivers delicious food
built on organic fruits and vegetables
like i just said right to your door
and it just takes a few minutes to
prepare and i never have the question if
the food i'm eating is good for me
and i don't even want to think about
prepping meals i don't want to cook
i don't want to clean after all that
stuff i just want to eat food
asap sometimes because like when i'm
editing videos
or waiting for people to edit my videos
like
i don't even wanna think about you know
you just you just get in the zone
and you don't want to cook right so this
is really awesome they never use
preservatives
added sugar or artificial ingredients
daily harvest works directly with farms
to freeze their
ingredients at peak ripeness to lock in
nutrients
and taste with daily harvest there's an
option for any time of day
smoothies for breakfast crisp flatbreads
for lunch or dinner and comfort food
for when the weather starts to cool down
like they're perfectly roasted
harvest bowls and hearty soups so
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to enjoy it helping
you reduce food waste daily harvest is
also committed
to minimizing their environmental impact
they're in the process
of transition transitioning to 100
recyclable
plant-based and renewable fiber
packaging we all deserve a break from
cooking with daily harvest i can enjoy
undeniably delicious clean food without
any prep keep it simple with daily
harvest go to dailyharvest.com and enter
promo code
otr to get 25 off your first box
that's promo code otr for 25 off your
first box at
dailyharvest.com so now that um you know
about
octopod octopi and they're your friends
now would you
never eat them again i never did oh you
never got them at sushis no
i probably won't it's just too
intimidating but what about squid no
i think if i didn't eat it as a child i
probably wouldn't need it either
i had them
[Music]
ceviche or fish ceviche but what if you
find out they're all smart and they all
have feelings
literally all animals don't say because
i had a taste for them as a child
you're lust for them you lust for them
have you ever seen a [ __ ] lobster
escape
they swear they go backwards yeah yeah
you do know
we're going to like see a [ __ ] yeah
we're watching the lobster the octopus
try to find a lobster and you know the
lobster tail that we eat
that's their only swimming propulsion
device so the octopus is trying to get
it and this was like
see you later [ __ ] yeah almost like i
got an eye on you [ __ ]
but how do they know where they're going
i don't even know how they know they're
going they go to the walls
oh yeah
[Laughter]
you're telling me octopuses eat lobster
every day well they try things
they're sick living yeah they like
blanket over them they go
and then they inject venom what do they
eat they eat lobster
what else mollusks clams shell uh
clam fish self they can like uh get
through this shell with their little
they have a drill yeah they're drill
things do they eat fish yeah fish too
i know they got a little beak which is
weird because it's like
a nasty looking bird yeah they got a
beak they got it i love
them they're my friend gordon ramsay
thing where he flew
to like i don't know alaska or some [ __ ]
probably not
he went ice fishing he drew they drilled
a hole in the ground i always wanted to
do that and then he went down there and
got a king [ __ ] crab like oh bigger
than
that
like he went in the hole he did it he
scooped it
and he pulled that [ __ ] out that's
cold as [ __ ] not with the wetsuits
probably it was really gordon was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] cold and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] frightening so he was at
our la office oh really oh
right me and pat saw him yeah you said
he looked ragged oh ramsey you look very
dry
wow like very very dry he looks dry on
the show
yeah what's with his his chin has like a
dimple that's like
[ __ ] at an angle that doesn't make
sense well good thing he can cook
his face looks very wrinkly dude that's
what i thought
recently i saw some guy and i don't know
if it is him but he looked exactly like
gerard butler
versus but if gerard butler was like
homeless
like an old like he just did not look
cleaned up like the actor but he sounded
just like
did you ask him are you a homeless
gerard butler no because
uh he was so it was at a gas station he
was at the cashier trying to get some
cigarettes and i was waiting for the
bathroom
like in the bathroom line but i was just
like
but i thought the same thing to him like
you look really dry like just really
what if that's him it could have been
him probably they just make makeup
this was by the beach so it's probably
him because a lot of actors when they're
on screen they get a lot of makeup so
they look super and then the lights
are just normal you guys saw skrillex
getting cigarettes
you know maybe a lot of celebrities like
to get cigarettes at gas stations
at the beach i was at the beach too i
got a buddy who's a star
of a very of a very popular kids show
and
they photoshopped the [ __ ] out of his
face for like the product
launches and [ __ ] but like in real life
now in real life he looks like a regular
dude though yeah yeah it looks
it looks like like 17. yeah it's like
wild how they do that
yeah and he just wanted to be more
kid-friendly
yeah so it doesn't seem like yeah gordon
ramsay's trying to
sell toys even whiskers though is like
intimidating for some reason
because they just get rid of all that
[ __ ] oh like the five o'clock shadow
mm-hmm
yeah basically it's not threatening or
something yeah yeah like look at ellen
and like oprah
like they all have all these face
filters and [ __ ] they do
well the soft like the lighting oh the
lighting yeah and then when you see the
filter on the
yeah and ellen has a [ __ ] filter now
too because apparently she's got a lot
of [ __ ] coming out
yeah i had to put a [ __ ] filter on her
what's the latest on that because i
didn't keep up
i don't even know she was getting
cancelled right yeah i mean a lot of you
everywhere
i never keep up with everyone's tea i
don't either
i just know because i have like i
reported it and then after this
i don't i don't keep up with it but you
don't like drama i like to remodel my
bathroom
and like play with kittens i forget
about the world sometimes yeah because
like i'm too busy looking i think
because like there's too much going on
it's too overwhelming and i'm like i
can't help like it just feels like i
feel so helpless why do you feel like
you have to do anything well
because it's it's very sad it's like
it's your fellow human you want to fix
it
why is it sad that kim kardashian is in
trouble what
are they in trouble just oh no i'm not
kim or like ellen farted or like oh
those things that's just just taking up
mental space
oh i would rather do it are you talking
about like the sad stuff
right now with the like rona and like
fire
and like destruction and protest yes all
that stuff
i like it when ellen dances
she stopped dancing oh she's not she's
too much of a [ __ ] now well like she
stopped
dancing a few years ago because too many
people were coming up and trying to
dance next to her on the street and she
was getting annoyed
that's [ __ ] hilarious she stopped
dancing she invited that
that was a hint yeah that was a hint
what happened to her be
kind [ __ ] slogan everyone that says
that is a [ __ ]
she says it until they yell it's a
reminder she believes that until they
yell cut
damn oh maybe she's in character the
[ __ ] out of here
when do we promote that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
what's more important though like
someone that has a fake be kind persona
but because of that and before you see
past like the the velvet [ __ ]
curtains
it does spread a lot of positivity but
they're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
or uh now that we just know they're a
[ __ ] and there's no one spreading
positivity at all listen dude
if you seem a certain way you better be
like a 24 7 365.
i used to think like you now i'm like no
no or what if she was
a be kind person until people pissed her
off
and she's like [ __ ] the world because we
have friends like that that are
genuinely like sweet [ __ ]
and then like entertainment made them
weather oh yeah
well she did she did come out on
national on her national
television show and then their show got
cancelled that sucks
what do you mean like she's like i'm gay
and then they're like can't talk yeah
that's exactly what happened
someone literally pulled the plug right
when she said it yeah when it was in the
90s she had a gigantic plug
they weren't ready for the lesbians in
90s no and they
like that so that could cause some
resentment you know they were starting
to warm up to it because remember um
what's that
grace that one it came out like right
after that like a couple years after
that
but yeah for some reason they were more
accepting towards men
than than gay women yeah the l word
that's way longer that was later really
i like lesbians
yeah hell yeah i wish i was over there
too
but the world was not ready
you